[Music]
okay I just have to ask you something
that keeps popping up again and again
and again how good this tomato soup well
the tomato soup is great why do they why
do people keep wanting you to run for
president what is that I don't know what
why would you not want over it around
for no no I'm just curious because
people are saying 2020 now is done yeah
that's not that happened that is just
not gonna happen
okay yeah just because that would not be
my strength my strength is bringing
people together my strength is
connecting people to ideas my strength
is allowing people to see the best of
themselves even than the worst of times
and circumstances that is not my thing
that would not be what I would be able
to do well politics doesn't do that does
it it doesn't do that for me but I would
get behind somebody who I really truly
believed in and would work my butt off
to to make them as successful as
possible I don't know who that is right
now because I know there's gonna be the
next question so don't go down I was
gonna ask you what's the next food
[Music]
you